do you know what I mean no what is your
favorite social media app I'd say
Instagram it's just fun you know it's
like one of those things where like you
know you can just you can just let loose
and like you know through the media like
you know and you can like let people let
people in on your life I think that's my
son's favorite too
that's how I can keep traffic yeah yeah
talk to me does he's like this ok dad ok
there do you have any advices how to
build followers I don't know how to
build followers but I know how I keep
followers is that's my outlet to
communicate with people Facebook that's
for my family Mia familia
but then there's Instagram where that's
like hey baby hey world what's up it's a
open space everybody who's struggling I
want them to come to me so I talked to a
lot of people all my followers all the
time and how do you do that through a
picture
well it's through like dance you know
like hate the enemy direct message I
don't even know what that is tell me
about your experience with social media
some of your anxieties you people will
find any reason to like make someone
feel bad about themselves that's just
people you know social media is just
like the platform that makes it easier
for people to do that
right if you're you know posting for a
good reason and you're posting because
you want to post what you want to post
like I think it could be a really really
good resource for you to like get
yourself out there how about when you're
walking in a parking lot or walking down
the street are you on your phone if if I
don't want somebody to talk to me yes
pretend like I'm doing something but I'm
just staring at my wallpaper which is
fabulous by the way it's concerned me
when I'm driving and I stop and they're
gonna cross the street and they don't
even look to see if I'm turning right or
anything they do keep walking into right
out into traffic don't
somebody you're gonna kill yourself
because I see these people okay I don't
hear you getting the perfect room
showing angles are definitely everything
you're gonna get in this okay yeah
you're gonna my youngest son he's always
taking pictures in the car in the
kitchen everywhere where's the me and
I'm a teenage girl
[Music]